hey guys my name is alvin and i love
noodles they're delicious they're
comforting they're super super fun to
eat you really can't go wrong with a
bowl of noodles no matter what time of
day it is i think it's a great thing to
be able to cook no matter how much time
you have on your hands so i brought in
my friendship eric who's going to show
you guys how to make a one minute one
hour and one day noodle take it away
eric
what's up everybody my name is eric zee
i'm the chef owner at 886 taiwanese
restaurant and today i'm going to show
you guys how to make a one minute one
hour and one day noodle
you know those days when you just don't
feel like cooking at all or you're super
hungover or you just you gotta run a
class or something so the one minute
noodle is super simple it's just a
noodle and a sauce the reason why the
sauce is so good is because it has all
the basic components it has sweetness it
has acidity from the vinegar it has
savory from the soy sauce
so this noodle was my go-to recipe
during college so my roommate you would
always be hungry and be like yo eric can
you cook me something up and one night i
just took whatever we had in the pantry
and i threw it all together and bam
now for the noodles all you have to do
is put the sauce into the noodles it's
about
half a cup mix the noodles real well
just so the sauce really incorporates
into the noodles honestly whatever
noodles you have left over as long as
it's thin really alright so this is
ready to plate
pretty up these noodles a little bit
now we sprinkle on a little bit of
sesame seeds make sure they're toasted
it provides a nice little crunch the
scallion
here we have some minced garlic and last
but not least we're gonna use some chili
oil any asian supermarket you can find
chili oil laugama is
everybody's favorite i prefer our own
chili oil that we use at the restaurant
so here it is the one minute cold noodle
with chinese black vinegar soy sauce and
sesame oil
so to eat this bad boy all you got to do
is just mix it up real well
man
i kind of miss it
remember
[Music]
now for the one hour noodle this noodle
is called
which literally translates to fried
sauce noodle it's super traditional it's
found in china taiwan korea first thing
we're going to start off with scrambled
eggs for me i like the eggs kind of
charred on the outside like a nice thick
crust it's not found in western cooking
a lot but it's the more taiwanese way of
doing things for this recipe i feel like
it works better because it provides
the caramelized flavor of the egg and my
mom used to always make this for me and
the egg is ready so now we're going to
get to
the fried sauce part
so there's really just two types of
sauces
you want to caramelize them both so the
first one we're going to use is a
fermented yellow bean paste
make sure you hear that slight sizzle
the second one it's called the
tiamianjang
so these sauces you can really find in
any asian grocery store the yellow bean
paste it's kind of like a miso but a
little bit funkier and the sweet sauce
is essentially a sweetened roux so it's
nice and
sugary by frying the sauce you
caramelize the sugars inside and it
brings an extra depth of flavor transfer
the sauce into the bowl
into any separate container and we're
gonna
add this to the pork a little bit later
so now we're gonna turn the heat up
wheel high shallots or as gordon ramsay
says
shallots
some garlic
some ginger
and
here you just want to kind of fry them
get
you know get the water out a little bit
make have the natural sweetness come
through want to feel like you can see it
becoming more translucent and also you
can smell that the flavor the aromas are
coming through chinese food is
the trinity
ginger garlic and scallion we don't have
scallion here we have shallots kind of
the same thing but not really put in the
pork you can use any protein you just
want to make sure there's a good fat
content right here we have about 80 20
ground pork the goal here is to
caramelize the pork so you get that nice
meaty flavor so this dish takes a little
bit more of a prep you know you have you
have to cut your garlic
shallots your ginger
make sure they're nice and fine so then
they can cook evenly within the sauce
it's about these extra small steps and
the details of these small steps that
really makes the dish that much better
smells like my mom's kitchen i wouldn't
say mine's better
but it kind of is
all right so it's been about
10 minutes ish
the pork is nice and brown you can see
the
dark bits all we have to do is put the
caramelized sauce in
add some of the soy sauce
just so it gets a little bit more color
and now we
stir
make sure the sauce is very evenly
incorporated
give it a little bit of time to marry
with the pork part you got to be really
careful you don't want to burn right
because your sauce is caramelized your
pork is nice and caramelized now we just
got to add the cornstarch slurry
now we're talking
so we just need to add a little bit more
water
so now you see that the sauce is it's
not
super sticky but it you can see that the
cornstarch has gotten really
incorporated into the sauce
and it will really coat the noodles
super well so the noodles i actually
brought from the restaurant we buy it
fresh from a purveyor here in chinatown
new york city they make it fresh every
morning but if you're making it at home
store-bought ones are fine
noodles in
so for these noodles i cook them for two
minutes and this recipe is obviously my
mom's so every time i cook it i taste
her cooking and it's always that sense
of nostalgia that always brings me back
so when you're cooking noodles you
really want to interact with it you want
to look at how it expands and it becomes
slightly more translucent i'm just going
to strain this guy out
now make sure you get
rid of any excess water
oh [ __ ]
that was not pretty let's plate it just
kind of pour it into the bowl for me i
like to make it nice and pretty so
pull it up a little and fold
we have the pork sauce
[Music]
i
have cucumbers last but not least these
scrambled eggs
there you have it this is our one hour
tsajeong mian with caramelized pork
sauce cucumbers and scrambled egg so we
finished our noodles and it's time to
eat so yeah mixing it it's going to be a
little bit messy but that's what you
want it's always served pre-mixed oh
pre-mixed before mixed
unmixed it's always served unmixed
i know i should be saying something
but it's so good
it tastes like my mom's cooking i i feel
like i'm back home and i was 15 years
old just finished tennis practice
i'm gonna take this take it home with me
[Music]
all right we're here
this is the one day noodle
so we're making the taiwanese beef
noodle soup we start with oxtail and
shin bones these you can get in any
butcher shop or any asian supermarket so
short rib has a lot of collagen that's
going to break down into gelatin and it
has a lot of intramuscular fat so it
stands up to braising so while the bones
are boiling we're going to toast some
spices here we have coriander seeds star
nice
sichuan peppercorns
we're going to toast the spices until
they're fragrant and aromatic
just
take these guys out
now the next step is to caramelize the
dobanjan so this is
a fermented fava bean
it's spicy it's from the province of
sichuan so by frying the sauce you
caramelize the sugars and of course by
caramelizing the sugar
you have a greater depth of flavor
you want to be careful not to burn it
because this is a little bit drier so
it's been 30 minutes the bones have been
blanched so this step is to get rid of
the metallic flavor in the beef so if
you skip it you'll have that weird penny
tasting broth nobody wants that so as
you can see there's quite a bit of stuff
on the table
but since it is a one day recipe you
might as well go all in and every single
ingredient provides a certain flavor
taiwanese beef noodle soup every
household every restaurant has their own
recipe don't freak out if this isn't
your recipe or whatever you're familiar
with so this specific recipe is for our
restaurant 886.
we wanted it to have a slightly sweeter
more subtle vegetable flavor than just
straight up beefiness or spiciness we
have the apple and the celery so these
fruits and vegetables all contribute to
the sweetness and different levels of
freshness that you'll eventually get
from the soup now we're going to add in
the tomatoes in taiwan you would get
literally stalls that focus on tomato
flavored beef noodle soup that's what i
like to recreate
now we're going to add the garlic
we have the dough
we have all the toasted spices
so rock sugar is basically sugar that
tastes better and you get the subtle
notes of cane sugar time for the savory
we have soy sauce
so dark soy sauce offers color but it
doesn't overwhelm the taste if you
wanted to do this at home you could
essentially hit up one really big asian
supermarket and have everything bothered
just wanna fill it to the brim so all
the ingredients
are covered in water so now that
everything's in here we're gonna give it
about six hours to braise just so all
the ingredients can yield its flavors to
the broth and about halfway through
we're going to take out the meat so it
doesn't over braise then we're going to
have to chill it overnight it is a very
long time for a bowl of noodles but
trust me it's going to be worth it
it is now day 2 and
i have strained the broth and taken the
meat out
so as you can see there's a layer of fat
on top we're just going to take that out
smells like beefy tomatoey goodness
so i'm taking the fat out so later on
when we're making the noodles actually
we're going to portion the fat to each
bowl all right so we're going to portion
out one bowl of soup
all right so the broth is portioned now
we're going to cook the noodles
so these are the same noodles as the
xiaomian ones
fresh chewy and springy you're boiling
your noodles you're almost there hard
days of work it's going to be worth it
finish line
here
so now we're going to add the bok choy
into the water that we were cooking the
noodles with and bok choy really just
takes about
30 seconds to cook strain out any excess
water
gently
place them
so now we have the hot pan and this is
the short rib i uh took out from the
broth cut it off the bone and kind of
portioned it into semi bite-sized pieces
so we're just gonna start by
caramelizing them
it's really like finishing a steak
so you get the best of both worlds
since the short rib has been raised it's
really nice and soft on the inside
by searing the outside you have a nice
caramelized crust
so now we're reheating the broth
we're going to add a little tiny pinch
of salt this is where it all comes
together
one day of work for this one bowl of
beef noodle soup i promise it's worth it
and to finish a little bit of sliced
scallions and so putting in all this
time and effort you'll really understand
why people go out of their way for a
good bowl of beef with soup
there you have it
one day taiwanese beef noodle soup with
seared short ribs and bok choy
i've probably had about
10 000 bowls of beef noodle soup in my
lifetime but it never gets old i'm going
to go home you enjoy all right
all right and there you have it that was
a one minute one hour and one day noodle
i hope you guys learned a lot chef eric
is amazing and you really want to eat
the one day one and you live in new york
city you should go to his restaurant 886
there's amazing taiwanese food there i
hope that inspires you guys to go try
out some noodles they're really fun
they're really delicious and you can
really have them any time of the day
and remember there's always time to cook
so until next time
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you